i think our audience deserves some good
news and so i will be fair and we're
going to do a feel-good story and this
story is federal election commission
finds dnc and clinton over russia gate
hoax
refreshing your feel-good story of the
evening uh hillary clinton only got
fined i think a a small amount of money
but let's read according to a scoop from
paul bedard of the washington examiner
the election agency said that clinton
and dnc violated strict rules on
describing expenditures of payments
funneled to the opposition research firm
fusion gps through their law firm a
combined one million twenty four
thousand four hundred and seven dollars
and ninety seven cents was paid by the
treasurers of the dnc and the clinton
campaign law to to law firm perkins
cowie for fusion gps's information and
the party and campaign hid the reason
claiming it was for legal services not
opposition research instead the dnc's
849
407.97 and the clinton campaign's 175
000
covered fusion gps's opposition research
on the dossier a basis for the so-called
russia hoax that dogged trump's first
term
so i believe we have the numbers here
the report says the agency fined
clinton's treasurer eight thousand
dollars in the dnc 105 000
so um
it could be good news but i could i do
kind of feel like a lot of people are
going to see that and say it's sweeping
under the rug well there's more news too
the federal election commission was just
found dead
ah yes i'm just kidding just the
entirety of the organization just gone
overnight the organization died yeah
mysteriously in its sleep no you know
what i love about the hillary clinton
meme is that it like regular people used
it yeah like normies talking about video
games 100 like a video game company goes
out of business and then the fake tweet
appears like like and it's just funny
it's fun no but i think i mean this is
i have trouble getting excited about
things like this to be perfectly honest
with you because it feels like
the carrot they dangle in front of you
you know and i'm tired of having carrots
dangled in front of people and i think
people are tired of it they just want
the damn carrot they don't want a nibble
of it they don't want to keep seeing it
waved in front of them they want the
whole carrot they know what's going on
and that's the thing is and for so long
we've had it just yeah and it's almost
insulting honestly eight grand like come
on hillary clinton doesn't care about
eight grand that's that's the other
insulting part of it so i just i kind of
find it insulting more so than good news
i mean it could be the precursor to
something i mean uh donald trump is
suing
the dnc suing clinton or the dc he's
suing a whole bunch of democrats over
the russia gate hoaxes this obviously
will play very well into his lawsuit
yeah no this will help him for sure
but where do we where where do we go
from here if there is no accountability
for people like this who are still
running and as we talked about in the
previous segment that trying to stop you
from being able to go into congress
i mean i think we're going to see that
decline only speed up if if there
continues to be no consequences and they
continue to be able to sort of build
this machine that keeps out outsiders
then it's just going to get worse faster
you know whereas i feel like if we get
this right in 2022 and this is probably
the best chance we've got because people
are so angry right now
um at least in this time period i mean
you can argue a lot of things maybe in
2026 20 30 may happen that may make
people take a different route but in in
this election i feel like we do have a
great opportunity there are strong
people and not just in congress i'm
talking locally i mean what did we learn
from kovid who you elect locally
matters more than who you elect for
president in so many cases yep you know
that's that's what changed your life
during covet was who your mayor was who
your you know local sheriff was and all
that so people need to show up and the
other lesson for all of this though is
show up to primaries and local elections
they're more important than the general
even i would argue that because
we need to pick the very best people for
all of these positions what what's your
uh your district is
district five yeah it's a republican
district you know you know the cook pvi
is i think it's plus 12 now in the new
district yeah wow so it was actually
plus 17 at one point democrat um and
it'd been a democracy for over 100 years
but it was redistricted this year
because the population growth in middle
tennessee over the past decade has been
massive just exploded and it's largely
the exodus of conservatives out of
california new york and illinois
coming in well daily wire yep they've
got all our employees there's a bunch of
companies coming in you know i mean just
left and right companies because we're a
very business friendly state you know
we're one of those states with a zero
percent state tax to when you come here
so it's just very friendly and enticing
this means that the primary is the
actual election yes because whoever wins
the primary is going to win
basically no matter what yep so you need
to make sure all of you listening that
you go out and vote in your primaries
and your local elections
enough states uh we're really close to a
constitutional convention very close
that means if people all go out if every
single person who listened to this show
went and told all their immediate
friends hey we're going to go vote in
the in the in the local elections yes
i'm pretty sure republicans would win
these states well and consider this too
okay so this is the other thing we have
to think tactically so if you're looking
at elections right now and you say you
know what in my district it doesn't
really matter we're very safe we've got
a good person or there's no way you're
getting this person whatever it is okay
you can make a difference in other parts
of the country you can phone bank for
other parts of the country find races
that matter where it does matter like
you say i have to get that person in you
know there may be some guy on like a
podcast you really like you know like
with a cool name like robbie and you're
like hey i want to make sure that guy
gets elected go and actually do
something to that effect you know you
don't even have to live there you can do
it these are federal races but then in
the local side of things make sure
you're involved make sure you know who
your mayor is you know where they stand
on things because that's been the shock
for a lot of people they've found their
mayors are little tyrants who want to
control their lives let's make sure we
don't do that anymore let's elect people
who actually want the people to be free
to be hanging out with uh so when you
get elected you're hanging out with like
uh marjory taylor green and thomas
massey and the freedom caucus people
absolutely cause that's what we need
more of yes i hear that i heard more and
more stories from them the thing about
marjorie was that uh she came on the
show she's been on the show i think
twice now and um a lot of people
messaged me saying we only heard crazy
things about her we never really really
looked into it but then when she told
the story about how she forced members
of congress to do an actual vote on
bills yeah
i'm getting all these messages from
people cheering being like wow she had
the backbone to risk a lot of things i
can't like fully go into but she risked
a lot of things to support me and i will
always
always appreciate that and like i said
politics is a business where they want
you to stab your friends in the back and
i refuse to do it i will never ever ever
do that or you know talk down about
somebody who's been an incredible friend
or supporter and she's
she cares she cares about this country
she cares about freedom she cares about
people like and i think that's one of
the things that people would be
surprised by is even if you disagreed
with her if you just sat down and talked
with her she cares about our country she
cares about people and she doesn't want
anybody hurting you know but this was
this was an amazing thing for us to
learn uh thanks to the freedom caucus uh
and many of these other people is that
members of congress don't actually vote
on these bills yeah they just have
proxies and like there's banging a gavel
and just shuffling it through like yes
you know whatever who cares it's almost
like there's no congress this point i
mean look nancy pelosi pushes through
her spending bill nobody has a chance to
read it
whoever's speaker of the house
it was supposed to be at least according
to ben franklin the way he was
envisioning it was that it would be like
a jury duty summons you'd get a summons
to go serve on congress for a while and
then when you're done you go home but
people couldn't afford it well you know
part of why congress is so broken is
it's the fundraising side of things we
have a bunch of people who are good
fundraisers and they're terrible
representatives a bunch of people to
that effect and that's the reality of it
you know if you don't if you're not
either independently wealthy or you
can't fundraise like crazy and you're
just a really good person with great
ideas that can get things done like
you're not you're not winning your race
you have got to be able to spend money
in these races and that's what's
terrible is that it's created this sort
of system where
you have a bunch of people who if
corporations will come to you and say
like amazon or big farmer or whoever it
is and they say hey we'll give you x
amount and we'll throw all this money
into packs that are going to support you
these people take the money yeah and
then it is a quid pro quo and nobody
will admit it but i'm i'm admitting it
you know it is that's 100 what these
people are doing and it's why i refuse
to take their money because we need to
be able to stand put a line in the sand
and say
this whole thing that's been going on
this is what is ruining our country
nobody's going in there to vote or to
reading or to writing or legislating in
any part any segment of it and saying
hey
how's this going to affect like your
average family in the middle of the
country
what i don't get is how why does it cost
money because i started i made a youtube
channel in 2006. i was like wow i've got
10 000 subscribers pretty quick i don't
need money to run for office now i have
what money buys which is the platform to
speak so what do you need money for
example so i have a large platform and
that's what a lot of people ask me is
they're like well why would i need to
donate to you have like almost a million
followers via all your social media like
why would you need me millions of people
watch you blah blah blah they don't live
in my district you know maybe 24 of my
district consumes their content online
the rest of them either it's like still
newspapers they listen to radio or their
tv or they just they don't do any of
that and they're people who work they
work for a living they go home they
spend time with their family that's it
they're pretty disconnected from what's
going on in the news
you have to be able to send out mailers
you have to be able to make sure your
name's out there and especially in
primaries the number one predictor of
primary who's going to win is name id so
if you actually do a poll on just name
id do have you heard this name before
that person's much more likely to win if
they're higher in name id whether it's
good bad indifferent doesn't matter they
just know the name people are going to
be like starbuck that sounds familiar
you get my vote yeah well you know
that's that's part of the hope but no
you've got to be able to get this stuff
out there and actually make people feel
something about you you know and that's
that's a good thing whether it's good or
bad because you've got to stand in what
you actually are going to do you know
and in my case it's a good thing because
i'm in a conservative district but
you've got to pay for the ads that's the
other thing is that
ads are one of the critical ways you
know if there's another let's say
28 of people who watch everything that
they get about politics on tv if you're
not present in those ads you're not
there in their ad space in that time
they're spending watching tv but your
opponent is
you're in trouble you know and i've seen
that in a lot of races where there's an
incredible person but they raised just
not enough money to be able to do ads
outside of maybe one or two places and
their opponent has money from you know
all these corporate super pacs and they
can just flood the zone flooding the
zone is the name of the game they know
how to flood the zone in these places
where people consume this content the
person becomes more familiar with the
name and maybe their only familiarity
with your name now is that corporate
pack who ran negative ads against you
saying this person you know um
they they hate trump watch this video
where they hated trump and it'll be like
a video of this person doing that but in
reality the truth of it is it was a
video of that person playing a part
during a party game where they're
explaining what you do during voting you
know and they just took it entirely out
of context but the people watching it
will never know that you know
that's something you've got to sort of
be able to to battle you know if you
don't have the money to do it then
people are going to have the wrong
impression about you so like in my case
the thing they're going to go after say
he's to hollywood he's directed you know
all these people who are hollywood
values and blah blah blah you know how
do you know he's really going to fight
for you and it's like
what have you done what have you done
and if you can't fight back or credibly
like give people an argument for why
they should vote for you then they're
just going to move on you know and do
what feels comfortable i love getting
these text messages i just pulled one up
from this this past week
this is somebody running against lauren
bobert
and that's basically their pitch
that that's that's that's it i don't
like we don't like her and uh give us
money maybe not that it's maybe not
illegal the right way but running smear
ads
what how how can you justify taking
political money and then running an ad
to to make someone else look bad what
does that do with your political that is
all they're going to do in my race
against me because i have higher name id
than basically everybody in the field
and so the problem with that for them is
they want to make sure that's attached
to something negative so for them that's
hollywood they feel like the hollywood
thing is going to really hurt see
my whole thought on that is actually
pretty far out from where they're at i
think because i'm like this is what they
try to do to trump people don't believe
this crap anymore yeah you know like i
directed something that had a violence
in it or something like that it's like
yeah that was my job this is not reality
it was not reality it was part of my job
it's actually care about where you're at
on policy you know yeah they'll they'll
see that commercial was like and robbie
starbuck something something something
it's all black and white and then it
shows the other guy with like the
sunshine is like and this guy does the
thing well they'll probably they'll
search your name and they'll see you
talking on this show and something
they'll be like oh this is the guy yes
that's the real person it's good
marketing you know so and it depends do
they care enough to do that you know
that's the real question do enough
people care enough to do that to make
that search to take that leap and say am
i being lied to i think people are
becoming more awake to that and the
necessity of doing things like that but
you know the reality is is that you've
got to meet people where they are and
that's the big part of fundraising is
that and so you know you're at a
handicap if you say i'm just going to
refuse all the corporate money but i
think it's critical to the direction
we're going as a country
you've got to take that stand and a
bunch of members criticized me early on
they were like dude i get it i want to
do the same thing but you've got to just
do this so you win
and i'm like i would rather sell my
house
dead serious for my kids i would rather
sell my house than take money from
amazon
because that is just the beginning of
you compromising values we'll clarify
too i mean when you say take money
typically it's like they dump it into a
super pack and then adds on your behalf
yeah
you know usually they're like the you
know the super pac and the candidate
don't coordinate but they do it's bs and
then so if like amazon put however much
what would be their maximum amount that
amazon could put into a campaign for
someone could yeah
okay so in a packet's unlimited and then
what if you're just like thanks you run
the campaign you win and you're like
yeah buy amazon i'm not involved anymore
thanks for helping me like now i'm going
to do what i what i want to do
i've never seen anybody do it what what
typically happens when you're uh running
an illegal uh bribery scheme and then
you uh don't give the guys who bribed
you what they've asked for they come
crooked knuckles
well no that's exactly it is like okay
go off the premise of how this all works
if you really made a backroom deal with
some company that you're gonna do their
bidding and do what they want and they
dump in millions into your pack to make
sure you can go do that do you really
think that they won't go out and expose
you in some way because the company is
going to get a slap on the wrist but you
you'll get in real trouble you're an
individual it's supposed to be it's a
donation those are donations right
they're making donations which have no
quid pro quo attached to them well and
there's a lot of rules with the pacs so
like you know you're not supposed to
communicate or anything like that with
them you know as a candidate i can't
talk to a pack i don't even have a pack
but if i did have a pack you know let's
say further closer to the election i
can't communicate in any way with them
there's ways you're allowed to go speak
at events and things like that but it's
a very serious rule you can't you know
you're not supposed to at least but the
good people follow the rules and the
vast majority don't follow those rules i
don't think that i think there's like
three or maybe like five good people
yeah most people may be well intentioned
when they get in but then like you said
they're like look look it's corrupted
one thing you gotta do you gotta do it
yep that's the first compromise is the
last compromise because the minute you
start doing it it will never stop and
don't just keep going you just know that
when he got in office they sat him down
the intelligence agencies and they were
like this is the plan and the mission is
what we're doing he went no excuse me
we're getting our troops out it's not
happening and and they got that's why i
love the guy that's why i love the guy
you know people this is what's funny is
after he endorsed um the other candidate
in this race and everybody was like you
got to be so mad all these these news
outlets come nbc cnn all these places
like do you want to come obviously they
want me to go in and bash him you know
they're like we've got division in the
maga movement candice owens went against
what trump said marjorie taylor green
went against what he said his own
lawyers went against it and goes on and
on and on and you know
i was like this is everything you guys
want now i'm not going to do it i love
the guy like he's hilarious this is the
energy we need people who are outsiders
who are going to fight this insane
system they're going to make mistakes
along the way they're not always going
to be perfect but they're going to do
their damn best to do what people need
it feels like a plane that's going down
and we need a pilot to help us crash
land because the federal reserve had
this it's been going on for a hundred
years they've been printing and printing
and printing to a point where we can't
we owe more interest than we can pay
back now and they're using this global
catastrophe as like the covet shutdown
as an excuse to reset it yeah as an
excuse but it was headed like a great
reset a big really big a really big one
you'd call it almost like a gargantuan
reset yeah the gargantuan reset sounds
accurate
so um
i i just don't know how to i hope
someone can crash land it properly we do
need people with high energy that at
least what we need is like a a a
a shared vision of reality yes yes
this is something that is critical okay
critical to the future of our country we
have so many mixed realities right now
and one of the most unifying things for
a society is your fundamental ability to
agree on what reality is even language
like look at language in our country we
can't even agree on words right now well
we can but they're people who are lying
yeah but exactly but then they're
confusing people who are growing up in
this environment and those people who
are growing up confused you know i don't
blame them i blame the evil people who
are doing this
but what they're producing and what
they're trying to do is create the
elements necessary to bring full bore
communism that's that's my deepest
belief you know my family already fled
communism once everything they're doing
now is not new this is something that's
been done many times before and it was
done in cuba where my family had to flee
you know
this is not a new thing we just need to
wake up and stop it before it comes to
reality and destroys the future of our
country you know this is decision time
and we have a lot of people who have
decision fatigue in our country where
they're just they're tired they're tired
of making decisions but this is the time
where people need to be strong and say
you know what we've got to make those
right decisions we've got to we've got
to do things and make sacrifices now
because if we don't we're going to end
up in a situation where we're going to
have to make some really really serious
sacrifices
and that's the truth of it so if people
wake up enough and they say i can make
this small sacrifice now great
if they don't though i think we're gonna
end up in a situation where they're
gonna be forced into serious sacrifice
so you want people to just put forth
that extra burst of energy like when
you're near the end of a race when you
just can't run anymore in everything not
just not just with me you know not just
like oh go donate to my campaign at
starbucks 2022.com not just that okay
but like actual energy and everyday life
about living your values you know like
this disney thing i think we're probably
going to talk about right the disney
thing
don't go take your kid to disneyland
it's not going to ruin their life don't
give disney more money don't give money
to people who hate well there are a lot
of traffickers that are getting arrested
at disney over the past several years i
don't know i i probably wouldn't want to
go there anyway don't go there don't
give them your money show some strength
have a spine cancel your netflix account
all these companies who hate you stop
giving them your money see i i have no
netflix um but people here do have
netflix so it's like it's on anyway uh i
i when disney plus came out i bought a
year because i just it's always cheaper
just to buy the year forward and then
what happened was was the the uyghur
muslim thing and i was like so i'm not
going to be renewing it that's for sure
yeah and i just it's all around not that
good when we start demanding that our
values are actually able to be lived out
in everything things will change but my
point that i'm trying to get to is the
answer isn't in my opinion to tell
everybody to cancel their netflix i see
some people are mentioning they did
obviously you want to cancel your
netflix but the real answer is daily
wire needs to ramp up yes absolutely we
need to start producing more cultural
content uh people who are
anti-establishment it's not just about
conservative it's about your
anti-establishment your populist you're
libertarian these are the values that
most of us share
i tried uh i wanted to watch hyperions i
wanted to watch the new daily wire movie
but i can't watch it on my tv
because you've got daily wear on like
roke or whatever but i have a smart tv
yeah that means daily wire needs to make
an lg app guys what are you doing and i
i i think i don't know if they have the
sony app but our sony tv is android bay
so i think we can download a download
download the android it's a good word
download dude i'm gonna have to check
because i checked about three or four
months ago and i couldn't do it on a
sony tv but um you know hopefully they
have because i think that you are
absolutely right it's an android this is
a critical critical next step
we've got to you know fill these holes
in culture in every way you know school
choice is another example of this you
know i know it's a far leap for a lot of
people from talking about entertainment
but these are cultural pillars
and think about how different our
country is going to look if you told
parents you're like let's take a place
like baltimore okay they take
about 17 500 per child they earmarked
for them to go to public school
meanwhile they're producing
kids one out of 10 graduate high school
in baltimore proficient in math and
reading okay
that's not something that should ever
happen in america now imagine you take
that 17 500 you hand it to parents and
you say do what you want to educate your
child it is up to you your job you
handle it no strings attached from
government government is not going to
get in the way of this do what you want
imagine 20 of them decide to homeschool
and now you have 20 percent more kids in
our country staying at home with a
parent
for those formative years
what kind of cultural effects are there
going to be long term it's going to be
massive everything you can think of from
incarceration rates to you know
the jobs that people choose you know
family how long people stay together
everything will change everything will
change in society based off just these
small things that will change from
school choice and if you fill those gaps
give people choice and this is another
one you know daily wire it's truly about
not just getting conservative content
out there it's about giving people a
real choice
right now we live in a system in the
entertainment industry and everywhere
else where we don't really have real
choices it's basically you have ten
options of the same left-wing garbage
and that's it you to know that's why i
started making my own same with music
too i want to shout out this meme i
posted on twitter so somebody somebody
posted uh well so let's start with james
lindsay he said this is art slippery
slope fallacy you're overreacting you're
overreacting and then it's like you know
disney employees
and then i responded quote so what if
government employees want to have sexual
conversation
with your four-year-old uh in secret
and then someone posted this meme when
you tell a democrat they can't teach sex
to kindergartners and it's the arthur
making a fist well they're getting mad
well i fixed it i put when you tell a
democrat they can't have sexual
conversations with four-year-olds in
secret because that's what's going on in
florida which has resulted in all of
this that's what democrats want it's and
and i'm i'm i'm not going to mince words
because i'm just
anybody
who who knowingly opposes the parental
rights and education bill is saying why
can't we have secret conversations with
four to nine year olds about sexual
topics it's a pedophile agenda it's it's
it's complete groomer it's pedophile
adjacent at the very least but there's a
lot of crypto pedos you know what does
that mean no it's a pedophile agenda
cryptically so so uh
crypto pedo means there are people who
are claiming that we're just trying to
teach children why are you stopping us
and then they behind the scenes they're
like yeah about about sexual
conversations in private with adults
yeah there's that love movement child
love but thing is there's so many love
has seven different definitions it's the
very least is one of them you do you
don't do that with kids yeah this is
this is one of those stages of going
into communism because first of all it
fits a couple different categories
separating children from their parents
okay
communists love to do that they like to
separate kids from their parents because
fundamentally they need to take over a
parental role they need that child to
see them as a parent and that's what
bills like this do is push us closer or
not the bill but the action that they
want and why they're so mad about the
bill is they want to be able to push
those kids closer to the state being
mommy or daddy okay
and
if they can't talk to them about these
critical issues that are supposed to be
things that parents talk to their kids
about and teach their kids about
you know that's a problem for them
because that's that's getting in the way
of their agenda now beyond just that
this is just step one the next step in
this is if they feel like they can move
the overton window far enough over where
suddenly you get 50 of democrats or 60
or 70 or 80 okay with this idea that yes
in fact the state does have a right to
have a sexual conversation with a
four-year-old and share their own
sexuality and sex life with their
four-year-old if that becomes normalized
what's next it's gonna be a child sexual
rights agenda and that's what people
need to be woke to is that's what's
coming down the line next and if you're
not aware of it now and you don't fight
this and you don't do what you can to
stop this now then
you're just like okay with that next
step you know i got to be honest uh if
you go back in time
there was talk about the slippery slope
and it all happened and now here we are
10 years later and once again we're
having same conversations it's going to
get bad and
i hope i i hope that at least the
reality of knowing that there's been
some things that were correct about that
is going to wake people up enough to say
oh maybe there's something we need to do
differently here yeah knowing what the
system is doing yeah drastically changes
the system itself yeah the calculus has
changed you know and i think that's
something that we all need to take
really seriously i mean that's what my
wife does is you know she works in this
area she's actually launching a
non-profit to do exactly this stop child
exploitation because we've essentially
created a pipeline for kids from birth
to exploit them you know look at social
media how early kids are on tick tock or
how early they're on instagram pages
with absolutely no oversight and we
teach girls specifically that like
commodifying yourself making yourself
into a commodity and it's your body
essentially is a good thing that's the
stuff broken societies do dude i was
just thinking about little kids seeing
pornography on the internet like when
they're two three and four years you
know what the average age is
my guess is four what is it the average
age in america right now where
somebody's exposed to hardcore porn so
like a video is 11. that's 11 years old
that's documented yeah because kids
might see it not even know they're
seeing it when they're three years
that's that's the average yeah they
wouldn't be able to answer the question
when they do those things where they try
to figure this out they wouldn't even be
able to answer three or four so if you
just said you know that probably likely
happens to a certain extent you would
probably say that number in reality is a
little bit lower but that's the one
that's documented is that it's at least
11. it shouldn't be that way you know
and this is not we're not talking about
like them sneaking under their grandpa's
you know mattress and getting a play
this is really graphic stuff yeah this
is this is horrific stuff that they're
seeing it's the first time in human
history that i know of that humans have
been exposed to this kind of content at
that age and i'm wondering if the people
that are in their 20s now are the people
that saw that stuff when they were four
yeah in 2003 when internet video
appeared yeah and that's and now they're
teaching now they're teachers well i
have i have somewhat of a controversial
take too when it comes to porn and it's
that you know i feel like we as men have
a responsibility to normalize
the fact that you should feel
emasculated if you have to watch porn i
feel like we should try to normalize
normal sexual healthy relationships with
your spouse
and that you know porn in itself is not
doing anything positive for you like if
you look at things from a net positive
or net life drain basis it's draining
things from your life and nothing it's
producing is really good for you you
know just like we were saying profane
things aren't necessarily the f word you
can be profane i think you can be
pornographic without sex and not all sex
is pornographic there's way it's just
you know it's the way that it's
portrayed i'm not sure i fully
understand yeah
there's some that's like healthy sex
people enjoying themselves and they're
somewhere i suppose if you're watching
like an educational science you know
thing that's like very dry and and you
know just like an old man is going as
the man becomes but who needs that
though like honestly you know if you're
like a med school
you know or you're a biologist i'm sorry
if you're a biologist or you're in med
school and you need to see that video
you should probably pick a guy you're
completely wrong i'm talking about an
educational thing showing like organs
like you okay that that that's okay i
thought you meant like a play-by-play on
how sex work thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm
we'll see you all there